Welcome to under the skin where I ask
what's beneath the surface of people we
admire of the ideas that define our time
of the history.
We are told,
this show is sponsored by me and my
rebirth tour.
The next couple of shows are sold out,
but there's still some tickets available
for Salford second of August,
20th of September.
Tor Key,
madam 27th of September,
Lester,
first of October.
Russell brand.com
for tickets.
Now it's time for under the skin.
Have a look it,
get under the skin with me,
Russell brand.
Under the skin.
We look under the superficial cutaneous
surface of issues individually,
histories,
myths,
and stories.
Today we will be talking to will store
an award winning writer,
a man who,
if you were to accuse him of being a
photographer for even a moment,
it would smash any camera in the
district.
Is features have appeared in various
publications including the Guardian,
The Times,
the observer and Gq.
He's the author of the critically
acclaimed books,
the heretics adventures with the enemies
of science and the novel,
the hunger,
and the howling of killing loan.
We're here to talk about his book,
Selfie among other things and topics
that come off,
selfie to discover the ideal of where
the perfect idea of self came from,
White,
so powerful on wherever there is any way
to break it.
Dangerous,
spelled as a fair introduction will
often as extremely fair.
Thank you Russell.
Thanks for coming on our show,
mate.
It's really nice to talk to you now.
This is one.
Those ones were like,
I don't.
We don't know each other,
but we've had quite a good chat before
the podcast started,
haven't we?
We have a very good chat.
Yeah.
We plunged right in with the nature of
reality as experienced through computer
games,
which pretty good place to start because
one of the things with this point in
this podcast is to.
I'm going to university doing this
course,
religion and global politics.
It may make gave me a thirst and an
excitement.
That knowledge I've always been proud
of.
My is in the Noyce or I learned that
mean and then actually I've learned some
things.
I think no,
it's really good to distill and to
understand and have some of the language
of academia.
So that's the point of interest is you
know,
what's this book Selfie?
I've just read a brief intro and
obviously understand what the modern
term means.
What do you want people to get from
reading that book?
What it is is the,
it's the,
it's the story of the Western self.
So what it's doing is saying that,
you know,
in,
in our modern culture we're surrounded
by this image of the perfect self and
it's a really particular kind of odd
image.
It's this person in their twenties and
they have this fat stomach and they kind
of are very entrepreneurial and they're
kind of globally minded and they kind of
look a certain way and act a certain way
and it's really sort of telling the
story of,
you know,
who is this person and and kind of how
it,
how did it come to be?
What'd you reckon that's come from
classicism?
Yeah.
So I think the story really begins for
me two and a half thousand years ago in
ancient Greece and I was really amazed
by this whole body of psycholo
psychological research I came across
that talks about this idea of the
geography of thought and it's this idea
that who we are as a people is very much
a product of all.
Back then it was geography.
So in ancient Greece is a code really
particular an unusual place.
So it wasn't like a nation of what you
think of.
It just acts like 100 individual city
states and there was a very particular
ecology and ancient Greece.
So it's mostly,
I mean,
I'm sure you've been to Greece,
but like it's mountains descending to
see a little rocky islands.
So what you couldn't do in ancient
Greece was you couldn't be like a
farmer,
like in East Asia,
there was like big,
big irrigation projects as big rice
grain projects.
So to get along and get ahead of it at
the same time.
Yet at the same time in,
in East Asia,
uh,
you know,
you had to be a part of a collective
enterprise.
But in ancient Greece it was different
dsp,
a hustler because there was no big
industry,
so you have to be a potter or uh,
or you know,
to make olive oil or to be a fisherman
and um,
and so you had to be yet to sort of push
yourself forwards.
And the other kind of ramification of it
being so coastal was that they started
trading with all these other countries
and so they began sharing ideas and
coming across sort of new and novel
ideas.
And that kind of encourages is this a
tradition of debate?
So debate was like a big thing you could
do and,
and so,
so the,
the ecology forms this kind of way of
being this kind of individualistic way
of seeing the world.
And then from that comes all these ideas
of,
you know,
what is a human,
what a human is,
this kind of individual node of
potential perfection and destiny rather
than us being a collective,
uh,
part of,
just,
just one could have node in a kind of
collective reality.
So you see interesting things in ancient
Greece beginning,
obviously there's the myth of Narcissus,
which is very relevant today,
but things like that,
they venerate celebrity do the myth of
narcissus just in case people are
listening to this,
I don't know nothing about.
And it says,
I've been listening to me for anything
because a pretty good idea.
Well let's say in ancient Greece that,
you know,
they,
they had,
they had this kind of version of
celebrity and they would tell you know,
these,
these great myths and one of one of them
has courses.
It's got narcissists who fell in love
with his own own image and the other
thing that you get literally then it is
reflection and then fault.
Oh my God,
this kid is lovely.
Yeah.
I think I'd like to get in there and
snuggle him.
And then did he drown?
Think he drowned?
Yeah.
In a way it's stupid like not to go out
on them and it was like a moment ago and
he's wearing those earrings and that top
I put on reflection,
but I suppose the point of a myth,
sorry about that noise that we were in
this place where there's continual
construction,
maybe it's a metaphor like,
like it's as opposed to the point of
that myth is about how it's easy to get
lost in the self and to make this self
total.
And that's why it's relevant.
New York.
It's no coincidence that the ancient
Greek myth,
because it was this,
it was this whole environment where the
individual was seen as this node of kind
of possibility.
And so I contrast this in Selfie with
what was going on in,
in,
in East Asia at the time.
And that was the land of Confucius.
And so to get along and get ahead in,
in East Asia,
you had to,
you know,
be part of this sort of big group.
And their idea of the perfect stuff was
totally opposite to the aristotle.
He notion,
uh,
you know,
the,
the idea of somebody who seeks notoriety
was,
was known as the inferior self and the
superior self doesn't seek that
notoriety,
so and so that,
that all feels like ancient history and
it is ancient history,
but it's all really relevant today.
So when these psychologists do these
studies on,
on Westerners versus East Asians,
they say that they,
they literally see the world in,
in a different way.
So if you put a Westerner in front of,
uh,
they,
they show a video of a fish tank for
three seconds and then the front of a
fish tank because this very flashy show,
offy narcissistic kind of fish,
right?
And,
um,
it sounds like a bloody good guy.
He's that and then monitor the movement
of your eyeballs every millisecond.
And what they find is that if you're a
westerner,
you will pretty much be studying that
individualistic,
narcissistic fish at the front.
But if you're from East Asia,
your,
I will be constantly moving and judge
looking at the context.
So they're literally seeing the world in
a different way.
And this has major ramifications even
down to how we take selfies.
So when you,
when they,
when they study the content of selfies,
East Asian selfies are much more likely
to be a big group of mates,
a big gang of people together.
But Western self is a much more focused
on the individual narcissistic face.
So huge sort of huge ramifications.
And it all begins with the ecology of
our people 2000 years ago,
which I just found extraordinary.
Well,
I like that story.
That's a good story.
I like to think about that little show
of fish.
I can't stop thinking about him.
I want to see him.
He sounds like a right little,
lovely name getting more out if me that
have tried to track my own movements
that have gotten always looking at it.
He's putting his hand in the fish tank
kitchen named Caitlyn it.
Even in his own name,
he took it off.
I might come back yet.
And that to follow me on.
CCTV footage just darted off.
So I'm like,
the things that we think of as the
central such as our attitude towards
individualism are themselves constructs.
And you can trace historical narratives
because we added me near that Yanis
Varoufakis you couldn't have been
clever.
He said one of the things he said,
well sure,
I liked it.
I've been saying it myself ever since
then.
And sometimes I don't credit him with
it.
There's no such thing as self.
He says you guys,
uh,
we exist in dialectic dialectically
existing conversation with others.
In fact,
I think it's even in my standup now and
I like it.
Yeah,
it's one is a good bit.
Like I talk about the notion of like,
you know,
how can you individually exist without
relationship,
you know,
so like,
like any years actually Greek,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I found,
I was thinking about like,
you know,
like the tradition of democracy within
reason come out of grace,
didn't it?
Because the thing I think about when he
was talking about the itemized
and entrepreneurial society,
which fate,
individualism also had slavery in it.
That might be craft bloody lazy path.
Yeah.
We about two and a half thousand years
ago.
So democracy.
Yeah,
still wasn't right.
It was a narrow as bullying number of
men that could vote for that.
It was only 50 years at democracy.
It was,
it was kind of a bit of a flash in the
pan,
but the fact that it came to existence,
even for that narrow range of news was
it was pretty extraordinary because
think of that in these days though.
Fifty years you'd think when you're like
50 years ago now the sixties,
you're feeling like,
you know,
that's like the other people.
So like,
you know,
but like if something,
if we create some sort of utopia that
lasted for 50 years,
it was a denim democratic utopia.
But regardless of what you're saying is
that the crucible of individualism as we
regard it,
started there with this particular
tradition that we can contrast to a
different tradition and that to this day
you can see even in simple prosaic
example such as a Selfie or people bug
out of show off fish and also a major
one.
So,
you know,
one of the,
this Guy Richard Nisbett,
who's the professor kind of studies this
as a pioneer of this guy,
said to me that,
um,
you know,
in China for example,
the idea of somebody suffering unfairly
for the benefit of the group is far more
acceptable to them.
To us that's a horrific human rights
abuse,
but it's much more acceptable in that
culture because they privileged the
group over the individual.
So there,
there are also bad effects.
So I'm not sample of someone's suffering
for the group.
Well,
so some of the human rights abuses that,
the communist dictator mind that,
well,
I mean,
so they don't mind it,
but,
but they're much more prepared to kind
of tolerate abuse.
They privileged the group and you know,
I talked to a Japanese anthropology
talks about,
you know,
the culture in Japan that a CEO of a
company might commit suicide if they've
let the company down and that might be
seen as an honorable act in Japan still
today.
Right?
Well,
at least he killed himself.
He did the right thing.
And that's almost a cliche though,
isn't it like a kamikaze idea.
And sort of slightly different,
I'm sure it's less prevalent today,
but you mentioned her,
she was saying that it's still secret,
still going to generally understood as
to understand why you would do that.
And she had even in informal parties,
if she,
she,
she says,
you'll introduce yourself to somebody
who's.
Hello,
I'm so nice,
David,
you'll,
you won't say I'm David.
And then it comes up in conversation a
bit later on that you work for Sony.
You say,
hello,
I'm Sony's David.
So the idea of the group is much more
front and center in their consciousness
on David by either look at more new
shoes.
You can always that shrimp salad.
Oh it's for everybody.
And we in the lot of way work for Sony.
That's why I'm here.
That's aristotle and yeah.
Yeah.
And then why would you identify with the
corporate entity?
So they say,
well you do think that capitalism does
this.
Then it means that because everything is
stripped and made it into an economic
model that people don't feel any sort of
sense of purpose or identification other
than their own individual sort of
identification with themselves because
communal values have been sort of
radically and dramatically broken down
over time to lose.
We think of ourselves as consumers.
That becomes our role.
Got No social order would.
That's the story that handily,
that Selfie,
it was absolutely so,
so,
so the,
so the beginning of the book,
we begin with how the ecology led to a
certain way of being an introduce.
It's kind of the foundational idea with
the book and that is that when we're
born,
it's as if the brain asks at one
fundamental question,
it says,
who do I have to be in this environment
in order to get along and get headed in
this tribe that I'm in and you know,
and there are sort of various
interesting sort of neuro biological
things that happen.
You know,
the brain kind of calms itself down as a
function called neural pruning.
We're actually carved itself down,
um,
to kind of meet the culture that it
finds itself immersed in.
And you're right,
so,
you know,
during the middle part of the 20th
century,
it was actually much more of a
collective time in the West in both,
you know,
it was a time of welfare state.
It was a time of unionization.
It was a time of a regulation on banking
or businesses job for life.
And what sprang out of that environment
where the hippies,
we had this very communalistic worldview
and if you compare who we were in 1965
to who we became in 1995,
that's 20 years,
that's half a generation.
It's an absolute transformation in who,
who we are.
What happened right in the middle of
those dates,
neoliberalism Thatcher and Reagan came
along and said,
right,
forget all this collectivization.
I found this interview that you did in
1981.
Really quite sinister where the stipend
senator Tom said,
all right,
mom,
Margaret Thatcher,
you know,
what's your plans,
what are you going to do?
And she said,
Oh,
you know,
things made me kind of very cross about
our policies for the last 30 years.
It'd been very collective and I want to
sort of bring back individualism and
that's a kind of.
I'm paraphrasing there,
but what then what you said is the
object is sort of method is economics,
but the object is to change the soul.
She wanted sinister and it's especially
because that's exactly what she did.
Couldn't both though the economics,
but the object is the truth.
That's exactly what she said,
Margaret.
I mean not actually as a person,
but it's a character that you don't just
look at people with detached from the
actual reality of what they historically
did and just sort of think of him as a
character because like Margaret
Thatcher,
mum had said he had to write a poem
about Alliance for state the windshield,
that de facto state funeral.
I'm like,
he said he looked at videos to inspire
him and he said that when you watched it
you sort of think,
oh my God,
he's brilliant because he's so forceful
and powerful and very opposite of the
incipient managerial technocrats that
find themselves in a position of
government today with the notable
notable exception of Donald trump.
But so like there was a clip that's
very,
that is a curious observation that there
was a sort of an agenda to change the
way the individual.
So that relationship with society out in
a central level.
Yeah.
And,
but I mean,
you know,
so obviously she had no understanding of
this rich and visit work because it
hadn't happened yet,
but she was absolutely right in what she
did.
I mean,
and it happens really quickly.
So in 1992,
what you find is something really weird
happening in our maternity wards.
So for generations,
parents called their children by Richard
Elizabeth Margaret,
like ordinary names.
And suddenly you get parents finding
unusual and distinctive and kind of
crazy names for their kids because they
want their children.
Their words are,
the psychologists have found this out to
stand out and be a star is the beginning
of the keep fit revolution and then by
the middle of the atheists we have the,
we have the Yuppies,
you know,
so,
so we start changing because who we have
to be in order to get along and get head
has been redefined by neoliberalism of
course,
near near liberalism is this idea that
they wanted to gamify all of human
society,
the ones that are human life into a
massive competition of self first itself
to get rid of the welfare state as much
as possible.
Get rid of the unions,
get rid of all that red tape is they
called it.
Everybody has to look after themselves
and you know,
that's what we find today.
You know,
young,
young people are these very ancient
Greek nodes of individual profit and all
their brands,
their entrepreneurial,
you know,
it's Kinda Thatcher's wet dream in a
way.
Disturbingly,
that's kind of what we see today.
I'm just thinking about Margaret
Thatcher having a way to it.
Thinking about the clammy of Maggie
Smash.
Yeah.
And I like don't dislike the idea,
I'll be honest with you,
will,
I'm enjoying it.
I may revisit that Meryl Streep film the
Iron Lady with this in mind.
She's dreaming of millennials.
That's who those are,
the people that are in that dream,
but do you.
Right?
So,
okay.
So you talked about the plasticity of
the mind prune in itself to be opera
bull in whatever context it finds
herself in.
But if they're,
you know,
this is a 50 years be a sort of a period
of a democratic blip in ancient Greece
or the journey from collectivism to
massive individualism from the sixties
to present day is a small period of
time.
Excuse me,
from an evolutionary perspective.
So don't you reckon that is in right
about really.
And we'll be able to turn people nicest
pie
shake of title.
Well I think there are,
there are causes for optimism.
So in the book or you know,
I,
I write about sort of trump and brexit.
I know we don't think about those things
in terms of optimism usually,
but I'm in.
I kind of connect those with the rise of
Corbin because I think what we're seeing
is the beginnings of a mass rebellion.
Yeah.
Against
neoliberalism.
Could it be a handsome young Jeremy
Corbyn yourself in that moment saying,
oh thank you.
I'll take that as a copay picture.
There'd be a video of asked.
See to see that.
Yeah.
Well there's a couple of minutes and it,
because,
well I started to like about Jeremy
Corbyn was that it was still and sort of
like,
you know,
before all of the sort of hubbub of the
laugh,
the election and they're,
you know,
their various leadership campaigns
within the Labor Party.
There was an idea that it was a bit
fuddy duddy and you can see that sharp
and him up suit wise,
but like an hair cut by Zambia dwis.
But now I like is this sort of stillness
and when he's on things being sort of
badgered and berated that he has a kind
of like he's been through it so many
times,
you know,
I,
I kinda like it.
And yes,
evidently it is what I felt like,
you know,
if there is a corollary between trump
and corbin,
it's authenticity,
that these are both people that feel
genuine and like there's an integrity.
We talked to Naomi Klein and she said,
yeah,
but Donald Trump's at massive liar,
but there's a brazenness to Donald
Trump.
There's something brazen that like,
compared to the light,
the Hillary Clinton never all
crap politician he's going on about how
about a bomber is the founder of Isis
that's fairly brazen.
Wow.
This anything,
alright be prejudiced.
But,
but,
but I think what,
what,
what we,
what we forget to do sometimes in all
our re outrage about Donald Trump is
actually look at what he was saying.
So what he was saying during that
campaign was,
I'm going to build a wall with Mexico
and I'm going to make apple put a
factory in Wisconsin and things like
this.
And Steve Bannon,
his right hand man was going.
The problem is we've got it.
The middle class in America was built
the middle class in Asia and you know,
that's true.
And so,
so,
so what he was mounting was an argument
against globalization.
That's what,
that's what he campaigned on.
And of course globalization is the
neoliberal projects.
What nearly was want is to create off
the world one single perfect global
market.
And if you're a right wing person with a
right ring brain and you are fed up with
neoliberalism,
that's going to be what you're thinking
about is globalization is immigrants.
It's,
you know,
all these foreigners coming in here and
knocking our wages down.
But if you're a left wing person looking
at exactly the same problem,
you're going to be looking in a
different direction.
You're gonna be looking at regulation.
We need more regulation.
We need to cut this inequality.
We need to sort out these terrible house
prices.
We need to cut student debt.
So,
so it feels to me like these sort of
these big political earthquakes,
a terrible cliche that have happened,
are both responses to the same problem
just but from opposite ends of the
political spectrum.
There are our responses against
neoliberalism.
So I really do feel that this is the
beginning,
the kind of the tumultuous beginning of
a big period of world revolution in,
in our lifetimes.
The worrying thing is that because
there's such different worldviews
attacking the same problem,
it's going to be a period of conflict.
I think new worldviews are going to
emerge because I would like to defy
those taxonomies and systems of
categorization.
This is what I think could,
could occur because information can be
liberated so rapidly now.
I think it's possible.
Will that tells me a little bit for.
Go on one of my rant.
It looks a little bit about what you're
saying about like,
uh,
the bogus self esteem revolution and
it's reappropriation of sort of
religious and spiritual principles to
tell me what you mean.
So the heart,
the heart of Selfie.
I did a big,
big,
long investigation into the self esteem
movement because this is what was the
self esteem and movement.
What is it?
Well,
it says this idea engine,
it comes out of the human potential
movement of the sixties and seventies in
America.
So in all that,
uh,
s comes out of it,
so it actually begins.
Excellent.
This'll institute in big Sur in
California where I actually went in
there actually.
Yeah.
I went there for the book.
I just,
I go and do a big sort of.
What did you do?
A course?
Did you ever do a work?
She's in a really nice hotel down the
road,
call me.
There's this thing down there and I
remember seeing her and Adam Curtis
documented truffle archival look at him.
I went there to have a look at them and
they were,
they weren't doing anything else.
It was,
you know,
they have that yoga workshops without.
I did what this course called the Max,
which was this horrific kind of thing
about finding your authenticity,
but it's very similar to the workshops
they were doing in the sixties and
seventies a bit,
but it was all business ideas of human
potential.
What was going on in the sixties and
seventies when it was being in the
screaming at your own genitals.
Yeah.
So I tell these horrific Thursday note
for me,
Dylan,
they called them encounter groups.
So the I say so it's like imagine sort
of big brother,
but,
but much more intense,
you'd be shot in a room for hours and
hours and hours name with complete
strangers and your job is to be as
honest as possible to that stranger.
Well,
people had nervous breakdowns,
you know,
nervous breakdown when you sit down
nearly at one,
because if I start saying little things
going in my head,
I'd be locked up because it's too much
going on in there.
But.
But the but the reason they thought that
was a good idea,
it's important when stands because there
was this big revolution in America
thinking.
So for generations back through Freud,
Freud,
back through all of Christianity,
the idea of what a human being is,
a human being is bad.
There's original sin,
there's Eda was complex,
we are bad.
And then in poster America,
this guy called Carl Rogers comes along
and has this new idea.
He says,
actually,
no,
that's wrong.
Human beings are amazing.
They're fantastic.
They're full of latent potential and
what we need to do to.
Well,
you just turns out of nowhere,
a few minutes of brilliant where he was
extremely influential,
uh,
you know,
whereas you getting a bloody sort of
backbone from how come you can come out
with such a contrary point and everyone
goes,
no trouble as well,
always said was he got,
well,
again,
I think it comes out of the economy.
So,
you know,
so in postwar America,
the economy was changing mat massively.
So there was a big exodus of people from
the country into cities,
uh,
women were now in the work,
in the workforce,
much more following the second world
war.
So it was the era of Corp Man of
suburbia or revolutionary road.
So it's a much more optimistic
personality focused time.
So again,
it's,
it's always economy that underpins these
big changes in it and the big social
movements.
And it seems to me that the reason that
that may have had sort of tacit
relevancy because both the projects of
urbanization,
corporatization and mass
industrialization,
they're all turning people into a bloody
great big lump.
And so you need an accompanying myth of
individualism as a sort of tonic so that
you can get through your job.
Were you doing bugger all in your
individualism is reduced to me.
I'll buy this phone if you want,
without laughing.
Which I think the historical kind of
traditional historical theory about how
the world changes is a bit wrong for
exactly those reasons is,
is that they tell that crazy story of
somebody comes along with a new idea and
everybody's fluxing goes,
yeah,
that's a great new idea.
That's not how it works.
People have new ideas all the time,
but what we choose the person who has
the idea that feels right and it feels
right because our economy is in a
certain way.
So it's,
it's,
it's the environment that changes first
and then we kind of lock onto somebody
who has an idea that feels kind of
truthy.
So this was Carl Rogers and anyway,
so he,
he,
he was,
he was just like this guy that kind of
had this new idea that.
And that's why encounter groups came.
He pioneered encounter groups.
This idea that in order to become
perfect,
we had to kind of,
you know,
reach this kind of inner core or as
perfect as possible,
as perfect as are potentially artists to
be.
And so from a selling something in that,
that there will like,
you know,
like going on a journey of self
discovery and honesty would be useful
for an individual.
Yeah.
But,
but,
but there's a couple of problems with it
and one of them is the is the,
you know,
what is the authentic self is this idea
that if we just strip away or the,
or the planet has a nice.
It is,
um,
uh,
the society layers upon us that there is
this perfect in a cell that we know that
isn't true in a sense.
You know,
that there is no such thing as the
authentic self with the,
with the big caveat that we do have a
distinct personality,
a biogenic kind of personality.
But so,
so,
so how did these ideas come to the self
esteem movement of the Nineteen 80
[inaudible]?
So John Vasconcellos was this very
powerful California politician who,
uh,
who knew Carl Rogers and corrosion,
it's got sort of mentor to him and in
the eighties and the,
in the neoliberal is he,
he had kind of a kind of near liberal
kind of remix of these excellent ideas.
So he decided that he called self esteem
is social vaccine.
He literally thought it was this
medicine that we'd all take self esteem,
the self esteem medicine,
uh,
and cocaine stay medicine.
Oh my God,
I know,
but that you'd done your job.
But that's what he thought.
He,
he thought the self esteem was going to
cure homelessness,
domestic violence,
uh,
in a teenage pregnancy,
drug abuse,
everything.
And not only that,
he thought it was going to make us more
competitive contestants in this great
near liberal game.
So he,
he,
he was the second most powerful
politician in California.
And he proposed,
he sets up this three year task force to
investigate self esteem.
And he said,
I'm going to get these,
these scientists to,
to,
to prove that there was a causative link
here,
that if we give people high self esteem,
they will become more perfect.
That become better near liberal kind of
contestants in how happier and healthier
so.
So fast forward three years he tells the
world,
I've done it.
The scientists agree with me,
self esteem as a social vaccine.
That is an amazing transformation.
At the beginning.
Everyone's laughing at this idiot from
California,
like this joke.
He's literally a national direct Johnny
Carson's cracking jokes about this thing
on the tonight show.
You know,
he's,
he,
he's a laughing stock,
but then it comes out with his news.
I've done it.
I've got these seven University of
California professors to study the data
and they've backed me up.
Self esteem is a social vaccine and he's
everywhere.
Then he's big.
He's flown to the Soviet Union,
has talked to the communists about self
esteem is an oprah talking about self
esteem.
And then of course I'll protect,
gets hold of the idea and it goes
everywhere.
He becomes this kind of celebrity.
And the idea that goes around the world
and it changes everything.
It changes the way we raised our
children.
It changes the way we teach our
It's that whole era,
which I think we both grew up in.
All of your wonderful.
You're special,
you're amazing.
Have a Rosetta for coming 14th place in
the sports day.
And what you see in the psychological
data is from the 19 no,
you.
Narcissism starts going up.
So.
So we start raising,
raising a generation of children who are
more narcissistic year by year,
and then the,
the kind of cohort that came before
them.
And of course that's the selfie
generation.
These are the millennials.
And so what I do in the book is I go
back to.
I spent a year investigating John
Vasconcellos.
He's since died and his taskforce and
what do you mean investigator down
taskforce members I went to.
There's a big archive in Sacramento,
the selfish all their documents.
I've got all their documents.
I've got audio recordings of their
meeting.
Was it.
It was amazing because what some people
knew was that there was a,
there was a problem.
That data didn't kind of say what Fastco
Fast Evan Got Invesco Oakland,
Vasco,
what?
Vasco said it said,
but I tracked down one task force member
who described the whole operation in his
words is a fucking lie,
and he said,
he said,
he said I was in a room with it and now
he's.
I was in a room with vascular when he
saw the scientific reports for the first
time and he said if the legislature who
fund them,
if ledger to see what's in the reports
are going to shut our task force down
and he said from that moment on,
the whole thing got covered up.
So it's incredibly consequential
exercise and changing who we are,
which really did have a big impact on
who we are today was,
as I kind of sort of revealed itself.
He really was based on a massive delinah
deliberate coverup and I even tracked
down if I've got Andrew Mecca who was
his right hand man,
who cheerfully admitted to me when
interviewed him.
Yeah,
we covered it up.
We,
you know,
we,
we deliberately went out on a mission to
kind of spin our way out of this problem
that the scientists were saying that
there is no causative link between self
esteem and all these virtuous,
amazing results with my dancing
research.
Your ideas crap.
Yeah.
I mean I actually,
I actually found a tape recording of the
meeting at which the lead scientist,
a guy who's a sociologist called Dr Neil
smelser.
I actually found an audio recording of
the meeting in which he announced to the
group what the results were and he was
basically saying is we're not getting
what you want us to get it,
you know,
where we are seeing a link between self
esteem and good outcomes.
We're not sure if it's causative or not.
So what he's saying is,
for example,
in education,
you can see that people who have high
good exam results have better self
esteem.
So what Vasco thought was that the self
esteem was causing the good exam
results,
but actually what's causing the service
day.
Exactly.
So,
so yeah,
and then I found another tape from a
couple of months later we were people,
including this guy I interviewed with
getting blowjobs all day.
Good self esteem.
I founded say with this meeting,
I just want to suck letter steam right
out of their belly pipe.
Sorry about that.
So stuff that I've always found amazing,
uh,
of this kind of rebellion that happened
at this meeting,
including the guy that I tracked down
where they stood up and said,
I'm really uncomfortable with what
you're saying to the media because we're
saying that we found this link and we
haven't got this link.
So come on,
shut up.
It was just sort of get stuff done like
that because I would have fought self
esteem is a good thing.
Well there's healthy self esteem is a
good thing.
So there's a guy called Professor Roy
Baumeister,
who I also tracked down who was the
guide that kind of busted this if we
didn't much to track it down.
I just found his email and emailed him.
But he said there is such a thing as off
the bat side,
looking at pebbles tweaks,
bloke to get like an aboriginal tracker
to find him.
But now he of course he said there is
such a thing as healthy 70,
but if it is earned.
So you know,
Einstein had really good self esteem
will probably we guess Bhava dressing
up.
Did he say that to staff?
That pair of trousers twice.
Banks out there.
I'm to do some maths and that's
Einstein.
Everyone.
But it also is an interesting guy
because his father was a literal Nazis.
Father fought with a narcissist and
Second World War and as Roy Baumeister
said,
Hitler had high self esteem too and it
would appear certainly believed in many
of these ideas.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Mystery.
He's a mystery because I think he might
have been a bit down on himself at times
when he was on his own and felt terrible
will.
That's the self esteem,
the self esteem.
If that says,
says that all kinds of bad antisocial
behaviors are because it's deep down,
you don't love yourself about you.
Then what got you off on this mission?
Well,
because that was,
that was the kind of the story of my
early life,
so I was an idiot growing up.
Like I failed all my exams.
I didn't concentrate at school,
got in trouble with the police.
I was alcoholic,
drug abuse,
like the whole staff and through my
twenties I was in therapy,
flop my twitter is trying to sort my
head out and the constant refrain from
teachers at school from the counselors
was always,
you've got low self esteem and your
parents didn't love you.
I'd very victorian,
you know,
classic English parents,
didn't,
they never liked,
loved you enough and that's why you're
so unhappy.
And I completely bought this.
I completely believe this.
And I bought this idea that my problem
deep down was that I didn't love myself.
I had low self esteem and that what I
had to do to cure it was to get high
self esteem.
So I did all these things to get high
And then I spoke to this.
Roy baumeister found out that it was all
a myth and it was only like six years
ago and it was like,
oh hang on.
So you're saying that everything I
thought was true about myself,
this whole journey I've been on of self
improvement has been based on bullshit
and it was based on the language may be
um,
sort of bogus,
but what ultimately aren't we all
looking for some sort of form of what I
want to say connection.
It's not like you want to go round,
rambled puffed up on a theme or mad like
a bull frog snack or high as a kite on
silliness,
but you don't want to feel terrible
feelings of worthlessness.
And one could imagine that a childhood
that didn't have physical affection and,
and I don't know,
validation in it might lead someone to
not feel.
Yes.
Well I think,
I think there was a,
there is an element of truth in that.
So,
so where the book ends up is,
is with this idea of what is the self
and there is a quarter,
everybody's sense of self and that's a
lot of that story is genetic.
So a lot of who we are used is down to
just an accident of genes.
And so what I,
when I do my personality test,
what I am is I'm high in the trait of
neuroticism.
Neuroticism goes hand in hand with low
self esteem.
So if you suffer from low self esteem,
you're generally a high neurotic.
But because it's a relatively stable
personality trait,
it means that you can't actually do much
about it.
But you're right to say I was born with
a neurotic brain.
If I'd have had more loving parents,
I would have been brought up happier
but,
but this combination of a neurotic brain
and on parents that weren't very
affectionate isn't a nasty combination.
So they did have.
But.
But the thing is,
the point is you can't do anything about
it once you're in.
You're a pretty neurotic brain.
And Mum,
mum,
she couldn't have given me more
smothering theater.
Our mom,
she loved the hell out of there.
Oh Russ.
But you're very confident there's the
result.
So you can live a terrible drug addict
and an alcoholic and written with self
doubt and all that kind of stuff and
sort of fast moving mind that for
forever looking for something that
probably isn't even there,
but don't you think like that?
The isn't the,
some of the ideas I'm interested in
here,
we'll is that wherever,
you know,
wherever it's a biomechanical model that
we prefer over some kind of Mumbo jumbo
spiritual model.
Liberty essential self is interconnected
and they all sorts of important to me is
the possibility and potentiality for
change both on an individual level,
in a social,
cultural level.
I believe in change very much because I
was a drug addict and now one day at a
time,
no drugs,
different behaviors.
It depends.
It depends what you mean by change.
So of course if we can heal,
right?
So of course we can heal.
So I'm much happier now as a 40 year old
then I wants us a 22 year olds fucking
miserable.
It's 22 year olds.
But I'm much happier now,
you know,
because I have a good,
uh,
a wife that,
that helps me when I'm going a bit mad
and things like this.
So of course we can heal and you've
obviously been on a big journey of
healing,
but we can't do it is.
So the whole human potential idea that
we still have very much with us today is
this toxic lie which tells our young
people you can do anything you want to
do and be anything you want to be.
You just have to dream big and kind of
go for it.
And that's very inspirational.
But it's also very,
very dangerous because what it does is
it tells people that when they fail,
which most of us do,
it's their fault and that's part of the
individuals and thing.
We forget that the reasons that we fail
our many and myriad and lots of the
marina and brought in our environment,
we blame ourselves.
So the book actually begins with talking
about suicide and the regions that we
kill ourselves.
And you know,
that sort of the model of pathway into
suicide is one that says that.
We said overly high expectations for
ourselves and when we fail again and
again and again and again,
and we feel stuck in that failure,
that's when the cell starts to become in
a really dangerous place to combat that
particular issue.
Then I think the big societal way is we
need to stop telling this lie that you
can do anything you want to do and be
anything you want to do.
We cannot transform my personality.
We cannot be beyonce or Michael Jordan
because we decide that that's what we
want to do.
You know,
we have,
we are,
we are animals.
We are biologically limited and there's
nothing we can do about that other than
Michael Jordan is Michael Jordan and
beyonce is beyonce.
Yeah.
So they,
they have a particular biology which
enables to that particular acculturation
say in,
on saying it,
bulks and teller.
She's crap for the first eight years of
her life.
She's not that well.
That might make her better.
She must be bloody.
Absolutely.
I know I'm going to do an even better
record,
but why is it.
But like,
but like I look,
I understand that this idea of um,
happiness through sort of self
fulfillment in a very materialistic way
was always just a marketing idea.
But when you sort of think of the vivid
images of Coca Cola and apple and these
sort of glorifications of the self,
you know,
these ideas,
if you can do what you want,
you know,
like is that,
that idea,
I think he's merely suggested so that
you can fulfill it with a can of coca
cola or a new iphone.
But the idea of change and potentiality,
I think that this I think is very,
very important to people.
But I suppose where it goes wrong
perhaps is when it,
when there's a preordained idea of what
it is you're meant to be in order to be
happy.
Now,
speaking from personal experience,
I fought,
I've got loads of money and I'm famous
and have sex with every one.
That'd be great.
So I tried those things and there were
bits of it that were sensually
brilliant,
an egotistically rewarding.
But I found them all to be ultimately
our ultimately unfulfilling.
And now my life is based on,
you know,
admittedly we've economic comfort,
like I'm living in a degree,
I don't have to go out and do terrible
things to get money,
but like at all,
so like,
but like uh,
you know,
but I do,
but I'm living in a kind of an ordinary
domestic sort of life or partner have
trialed pets,
you know what I mean?
I'm not a headedness anymore.
I'm not living in a decadent life
because I think I was trying to live in
accordance with a myth that was untrue.
So I completely agree with that.
But my concern would be if we're left
with just a biomechanical model of this
is your limitations as an animal and as
an individual that people might settle
for a life that's fulfilling.
Yep.
So,
so yeah,
so there's a nuance here.
So I don't want to come,
come across like I'm attacking
individualism completely isn't,
it's not a sort of big polemic because
what you have to do as well,
sort of being a grown up is take a step
back and go actually individually,
ms dot pretty amazing as well.
Like what we've achieved in the western
two and a half thousand years.
It's pretty amazing.
We've done some pretty amazing stuff and
some bad stuff like technology in that
we look at New York,
we built New Orleans.
Yeah.
And a part of that is individually.
Apart from that is that we tell people
you can do anything you want to do,
he should shoot for the stars,
but we also have a full idea of what a
human being is in our culture today.
We,
especially on the left,
you know,
we like to believe that the human brain
is a blank slate and that we are all
born in a place of equal,
amazing potential.
And that isn't true.
We all have,
we're all biological limited in
different ways.
So we all have different talents,
different abilities.
And there's a guy called Brian little,
I speak to who,
who's an expert in this kind of
personality stuff.
He talks a lot about the damage the Self
Esteem Myth has wrought upon our people
and you know,
and he says that we need to give people
kind of equals and personal projects
over which,
which gives them meaning but over which
they have efficacy I ever wished,
which they,
you know,
there's no point in trying to be the
fastest man in the world if you are 86
and have one leg,
you know,
like we,
we,
we have to understand that,
know that the capabilities of our
children and encourage them in those
specific directions and not say,
yeah,
you can be beyonce.
Just dream big.
Yeah.
These values and ideals are probably
sort of erroneous and that sort of
established by capitalist consumer
template.
These other constellation is populated
body idols and icons of the capitalists.
Skyscape absolutely right.
It's the economy.
So at the beginning of our chat and I
talked about who is this?
Who is this hero is surrounded by this
22 year old thin stomach,
big boobed globally minded.
Entrepreneurial.
Yeah.
Because it's a budget.
I didn't know who.
Who is this person with?
This person is the hero of our culture,
so we live in a near liberal culture,
neoliberal environment,
and this is the hero of neoliberalism.
This is the person who is most,
um,
uh,
cut out best to survive and thrive in
the neoliberal environment.
So this is the person I culture is
trying to try,
trying to attempt us into becoming a
facsimile low.
He's not a real,
he's a,
he's a myth,
but actually it's sort of probably old
white blokes pottery masturbating over
the image you just described because
that person doesn't exist.
It's a cipher,
not a cultural myth is a cultural
construct and we're all tormented by it
to a certain extent.
You know,
we all want to be this person.
And of course as we get older and
fatter,
we,
we become less and less to that person.
And as you know,
and,
and that's why,
you know,
one of the most vulnerable groups for
suicide are middle aged men.
Because you know when,
when you hit your forties and fifties,
you've come up against these limitations
very much and you begin to realize,
I'm never going to be that person that
I've,
I've always been told that I ought to
be.
Yes,
that's right.
And your physical gestures,
you did that mate,
very close to the Nazi salute.
You as you gestured that the bloke was
outside and a bath and they think it's
because really where we should be
looking for this kind of resolution is
inward.
It's peaceful in our connection.
Like one of the repeated reframes that
I'm banging on about if that,
that all of these things that like many
of the discoveries that are made by the
sort of world of neuroscience,
which I knew next to nothing about,
uh,
and uh,
like it was sort of in sociology and
health and stuff I've already outlined
in spiritual principles.
And as we discussed prior to us
recording,
you know that many of the
particularities and sociocultural
aspects of religious doctrine that are
particular to the time of its
conception.
I can see that those observances ain't
particularly helpful.
But the perennial ideas of oneness,
that of self is realized through
communion with the whole fruit or
acceptance that the material is
transient and temporary lessons that
I've learned in my own life.
I recognize we're already bloody written
down in old,
old 5,000
years old.
The ancient texts.
And when some Swami said to me in India
like chillingly,
the material world has nothing else to
give you.
Now,
Russell,
it can take from
you.
And it made my stomach turn over when he
said it,
I knew he was telling the truth.
I knew what he meant.
Stop looking for it in fame.
Stop looking for it in money.
And on a daily basis,
I forget.
I wake up and I think,
oh,
you know,
and that's why again,
in the,
in classical myths there is per permit
us to go through the daily punishment
because he stole the file.
Sufis who asked to continually push the
rock up the hill because it's an ongoing
realization because the self is an event
rather than an object.
The self is the conscious awareness of
our own experience,
which I think can be brought into
alignment with a different kind of pace
if we do reject that external matrix of
ideas that were supposed to be heading
towards,
but I wouldn't abandon the idea of a
pursuit because I think that's how we
can change the world with that energy
drive.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think.
I think the one thing that individualism
gets wrong is,
is it in over sin,
over emphasizing the individual is it
turns it back turns its back on on the
fact that we are a tribal animal.
We are,
we are a connected species.
We spent over 90 percent of our time on
this earth as members of hunter gatherer
tribes of around 148 people for
thousands of years and years before
thousands of thousand years before
civilization go.
And so how long did that go on hunter
gathering?
Hundreds of thousands of years.
I mean the average that you tried to
find that specific date for the book,
but they're all wildly different.
So I ended up kind of fudging a little
bit.
Oh No,
hang on a minute.
We found a big tribal people cross that
ice plateau.
They're always argued about that,
but we.
Yeah,
but we have,
you know,
we had these tribal brains and,
and,
and we,
as you say,
we,
we basically.
This is a blip the way you said that 50
year democratic blip in ancient Greece.
Like,
Oh,
show.
I liked him,
but then I must band.
But he goes to site.
It's just a clearing in the woods.
We talk about civilization,
like it's some big deal.
He's like,
just for while the forest is cleared
back.
Oh look,
we've got televisions and towers and
then nature will reclaim it.
So for hundreds of thousands of years we
were quite happy with the berries in the
Huntington and the Shaman and now.
Yeah.
And of course I,
you know,
and so,
so,
so we kind of turn our back very much
on,
on the kind of individual on the
essential connect connected part of our
humanity is,
as you say,
well it's not in the book.
That's when I was living in Australia.
I did a story on him place called
Rookwood cemetery outside Sydney,
and it's the biggest cemetery in the
southern hemisphere,
so city of dead people and it's all and
it's all a kind of cordoned off in terms
of the culture.
There's a Chinese cemetery in Islamic
cemetery in all that stuff.
That's a bit of a downer.
You can't mix with the wrong group.
It's very tribal.
You barely meet with them lot,
but it's true.
You'll just be some mush as she is a
good point.
You know the,
it goes back to our tribal cells.
We are tribal,
you know,
even even in death,
we can't skip the tribe business,
but I asked the guy who kind of manages
imagery as a WHO's the worst.
He's the worst people for kind of
tending the grays coming back and said,
oh,
Christians by far and away all the other
cultures,
you know,
they keep coming back.
You know,
they,
they polish the grave,
they bring gifts and flowers.
You know,
some of the,
some of the racist have like annual
events where they come and have little
parties for the greatest westerns.
They come once or twice and then they
just discovered shit and that's
individualism,
you know,
that's,
even down to the kind of the unit of the
family,
you know,
once they did all their debt,
now they're irrelevant.
We much more me focused and I didn't
understand that at the time I thought,
why are we so bad?
But now I get it.
It's because we're individualists
because.
Yeah,
right.
We don't have,
we don't connect to the path with NCSL
linear tradition.
Yeah.
And it's,
the family were not,
were far less family minded than those
other eastern cultures.
And that Tuesday I miss you grabbed
that.
Where did they go?
Well,
yeah,
that's a folder.
Um,
say that when you were talking about
Confucius and like,
and,
and like having a different relationship
with self and selfies.
Is there anything in that stuff that can
be useful to us in a collective
ideologies that we could somehow ransack
propagate?
And I think one of the things that
surprised you from my research was that,
you know,
especially on if we always talk about
this kind of crazy myths they have,
that there was once a better time and it
was,
there was once a perfect English and
make America great again.
But actually there was a better time in
a way,
and I'm not saying she,
you back to that time because we can't
know because it's kind of changed
because of time,
but,
but the time,
I was surprised to see that the middle,
the middle 20th century was a time of
much more quality of the code that some
economists call the.
It appeared,
they called it the great compression
causes compression between the,
the,
of inequality.
There was much less inequality and that
was this era of regulation of high
taxation,
of unionization.
But it was also before globalization.
So it was a kind of a simpler time.
Um,
but,
but what,
but what kind of knocked I think our,
our,
our kind of individually selves into
that era of more collectivization was
disaster.
Unfortunately.
It was the great depression and it was
the first and second world wars,
and in those periods of massive crisis
knocked us into going,
right?
We need to start looking after each
other.
We can't have a world of war and
economic disaster and all that stuff.
So,
uh,
that's the thing that worries me is that
it takes a bit of a disaster to kind of
knock us into a collective reality.
Oh No,
I'm inclined.
She'll tell you that what happens is we
get shocked and terrified by sort of,
you know,
shock doctrine and she's called it low.
Get all terrified.
And then you act on the basis of your
individual interests.
And of course,
like it became clear and out.
Adam Kay says that the myth of a time is
often contrary to its truth.
So if we're told we're individuals or
individuals or individuals,
the reality is you are a blob of
humanity.
That's what said,
like,
we're all like,
yeah,
why?
And about our bloody air cuts and
selfies and our converse trainers,
I've got these ones that are made out of
nikes now.
Nikes,
gorgeous box,
fresh going to die.
Dying.
So I've got bit that worries me.
Very bad.
Imperfect I.
No,
no,
I think about them sometimes,
but it's actually basically I've just
got two little worries on the end of my
legs,
so I'm just thinking some get some
bubble gum on that burger.
What if the beech root folds on the Isa?
So we're thinking of ourselves as
individuals,
but really we're just being marketed at
and we're fulfilling our NATO because
most people aren't going to be a
beyonce,
but heroes,
we're not heroes.
Icons of often functioned in that way
now.
Like you know,
you hold that aspirational object up and
instead of being to express the essence
of beyonce is a woman who can express
her womanhood through creativity and
potency,
Feminine Goddess Energy.
But you'll settle for or I'll buy the
same headphones.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You will.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Of course,
it's all that's used for marketing
purposes and I think the other thing,
the interesting thing to think about
when all this is before any of this sort
of engine green stuff is all that tribal
stuff and the fact that the,
that we are a particular kind of tribal
species.
Uh,
you know,
we liked the chimps in that we're not
only groupish that we attack other
groups and you see that a lot on social
media.
So in human tribe as in the chimp drive,
the status is always changing.
Who's at the top is always in kind of in
flux.
It cook a chimp,
a troop leader will be up there for 45
years.
So we,
we are preoccupied with status and we
see that kind of
that was going on in the week.
We stray into anthropology a little bit
when we,
you and I talking because we are trying
to understand it in a central truth
aren't.
With that goes beyond the limited and
limiting context of civilization,
which is only a blip,
but saying the hunter gatherer tribes
would have been luckily little chimp
society with your only chief for a
minute and then someone's trying to
knock that off with a rock.
We're in chimps.
It's four to five years,
which is interesting because we see that
in electrocytes inhumans.
Exactly.
It's exactly the same.
I had the banana but,
but,
but that's.
But that's going to have social media,
isn't it with you like,
you know,
we're constantly worried about how many
likes we've got you.
I'll relative status,
status updates and all this stuff.
But the other thing is that is that is
that we are aggressively tribal like
that.
Like you know,
our,
our relatives,
the chimpanzees that we kind of attack
these other groups.
And that's.
I think that's another really sort of
dangerous aspect of social media is it
encourages these very ancient kind of
tribal circuitry in us that when someone
breaks the codes of our Ingroup,
we sort of go,
wants to go off and kind of tear their
limbs off in a sense them attack them.
But this is really ancient stuff.
This is really powerful tribal circuitry
in the,
in the human self that thinks like,
you know,
these,
these kind of twitter storms.
Uh,
kind of feeding off.
Tell us,
well,
what happened to you when you were in
Scottish modern history.
Tell us what happened to you when you
met a nice den.
Would the villain.
Actually he was the tribal guy.
So this is a really interesting guy
called John Pridmore who,
uh,
he,
he's just a classic eastern gangster.
Love Him.
Yeah.
He's a really interesting guy and he
looks exactly like you spent lucky's
about seven foot with big leather coat
on and bolt head.
And you sat there like with his fist
down fist or with a big watch down there
too,
if you want him to,
like you'd call that a kettle kettle.
Oh crikey.
But have a me baby.
But he was living his life in that
classic Wimpish tribridge way when he
was a gangster,
you know,
he,
he was an enforcer for a drug for the,
for the drug gang,
with the firm,
the firms and forth.
Someone didn't pay their money.
I'd kick a rat in the shins.
Yeah.
Well he met with him.
Was it torture and beat people?
Yeah.
So,
so some things will be naughty,
but in a gentle words to describe stuff.
Show up.
Yeah.
Well no,
they never shoot us because if you,
if you had to shoot it and then you went
into prison for longer.
So he had a machete.
Yeah.
He had a special.
His shirt.
He had a.
He had a special,
especially a bespoke leather coat that
had a pocket for a Jif lemon bottle with
acid in it.
Some sort of acid in it.
Bleach.
It might have been to put in your eyes
and a machete and the other one we
having pancakes,
but then he had a massive nervous
breakdown.
It became Catholic faith.
He found the Lord today.
Lord,
why was he important in your research?
Because he was my example of the tribal
self.
So he,
he,
you know,
he's,
he,
he's gang was the tribe and they will go
to war with the opposing tribe,
which was obviously the rifle drugs took
who were also trying to sell drugs in
these kind of west end clubs,
but also the,
his nervous breakdown was really
important as well because it tells us a
really important thing about the self
and it's the idea of the self as a
storyteller.
So there's this really interesting idea
from neuroscience about called
confabulation and it's this idea that we
all have this voice in our heads,
this kind of internal model of this
constantly writing all our events.
Tea,
yeah,
you know him.
So he's saying this is why you did what
you did.
This is what you said,
that this is why you're a good guy.
This is what you should do next.
But it has no access to the rest of our
unconscious.
So it's essentially making it up.
It's just telling you this story.
So,
so you have no access to the real
reasons why you're doing what you're
doing.
So it's quite terrifying concept because
it's saying that we have no real idea
why we do what we do,
what we feel,
but the only reason that we feel that we
have like we do is because his voice is
telling us and it's just making stuff
up.
So when he had his nervous breakdown,
what happened was he,
he,
he punched this guy and he thought he'd
killed him and his boss,
but when you put over a couple of nights
off,
John,
because otherwise you're going to get in
prison.
So he went back to his flat,
he started smoking a joint.
You put on some porn,
and then the television started talking
to him and saying listing all the things
he'd done.
Now John was brought up in a Catholic
household.
And so his confabulation immediately,
his explanation of music was where that
voice is obviously the devil.
And that means that he's telling me I'm
going to go to hell.
And that means that if I'm going to save
myself from hell,
I need to pray to God.
So he runs outside,
falls to his knees naked.
Not Naked,
unfortunately.
Um,
but perhaps with boner he was watching
porn and then and then and then he runs
and he runs to his mom's house.
He knocked on his mom's door,
get rid of the erection,
finish this off,
and his mom opens the door and he says,
what you're doing job,
what you do in John.
He said,
mom,
something's amazing seminar.
And she said,
what's that full week?
Just soak up.
And he says,
mom,
I've found God.
And she goes,
at 2:00
in the morning.
It was hilarious,
but that.
But his confabulation was and saved him
from madness was the.
Actually you've not had a nervous
breakdown.
You're having a psychotic incident,
which is what I believe happened to him
that night.
He,
he,
you know,
he took a story from his culture which
was a Catholic Christian story of what
reality is and what our place in that
reality is.
And it kept us out.
Just the secular narrative for what
happens in the consciousness sounded
deck chairs on titanic time and it would
just sort of saying that's it.
That's one way of describing it.
Epiphany,
the sudden revelation of essence or
breakdown.
I reckon in a little while ago I had one
of those things,
but because my.
Because I like to think that my inner
critic now,
that Voice of confabulation,
I think I've given mine access to the
deep deep codes that you're one like
that when you went through in that
research and nodal those recording.
So my inner voice now I think I trust
that little guy also.
Actually,
I don't entirely trust it.
I always use other people's information
and data.
Like I go,
I'm thinking of doing this thing,
and people go,
oh no,
that's a terrible idea.
Don't do it.
I've got older men further down the path
than me that it was sort of tell me no,
no.
Russell was was a mental breakdown mate,
but like my age,
it's very conventional.
I've understood that you sort of reboot,
but you question your identity and go,
hold on a minute.
What the hell have I been doing?
Like you just said about the suicide
staff and like.
So I think with your man there,
it feels like,
you know.
Yeah.
The interpretive tool was.
He had the vocabulary of Christianity
and we have the vocabulary of
neuroscience,
but essentially there was one central
event and that central event was,
I want to break out of the preexisting
narrative and anyway,
it doesn't matter does it if you term it
as epiphany or breakdown as long as what
happened subsequently as you stop being
an eastern gangster guy around for Jif
lemon of acid and the machete and start
being a monk,
it sounds like a cool thing is,
is it's an excellent point because.
Yes,
I agree with you.
It was.
It was great that he didn't end up
medicated in a psychiatric institute as
his Mother did at one point in his life
and it's also great that,
you know,
goes around preaching the Gospel to
younger children.
I love a cockney because I was thinking
just that bad cockney priest.
I would love a cockney priest and this
is got a cottony monkey.
It was really easy.
Well,
yeah,
he's around.
He's around it.
It was a very odd moment when I was
bothering him.
I was talking to my mom and it was very,
very Catholic and she said to me,
now is what you've been doing?
I said,
oh,
I'll just do.
I've been.
I actually interviewed a Catholic monk
was trying to say something in the
market entertainer.
Yeah,
and she's,
Oh,
well,
what was that?
I said,
well,
he's just a guy called John pridmore
this gangster,
and she went,
Oh yes,
I've sat next to him at mass and I was
at the same place where I don't know
what happened,
but like it immediately sort of carry on
your research a bit more with your own
family.
It was a bit.
It was a bit deflating.
I was jumping jump in there.
That'd be deflated by that.
Really.
Somebody when it sounds sort of movement
in the sixties,
you sit around,
rooting around in,
archive your own mother says,
I've met someone that you've been
interviewing and switch off show that
they have attention,
will say,
Gosh,
you should have done a lot of that.
Gang started like the sound of your
book.
A great dude.
Now,
what about that thing that I was saying
at the beginning of the interview that I
was playing a computer game and the bits
where it's a pirate and it's very like
when I'm assassin's creed and it's all
the elaborate missions where I'm robbing
Spanish galleons,
I like it,
but then when it goes back to the
subplot where it reveals that you're not
really Hispanic or you're not a pirate,
you're a man in an office pretending to
be a pirate and the Games you have to
play in the office of crap like Pac man
looking games.
I get bored with them,
but really you're probably on a motor
neuron level doing the same thing,
twiddling your thumbs about moving in
different directions,
but when you're being the pirate,
it seems like you're smashing over the
edge of a barrel when you're doing cool
stuff and when you're in the office it's
boring.
So are we essentially just one as a kind
of an experiencing entity?
Consciousness itself,
receiving data that you said it was like
electronical impulses and organizing it
into all different stories.
Looking for stories that are attractive
to us,
either because of some personal
inflection or because of the culture of
our time.
Validates and enjoys that story.
Yeah,
totally.
So my last book was got the heritage and
it was about exactly.
This is it.
It's about how we experience our lives.
The story about the brain conjures this
story.
One neuroscientist I spoke to,
Chris,
Chris described us.
The illusion the brain makes makes us
the,
the invisible actor at the center of the
world and what it does to keep us,
keep us motivated to keep her as happy
and kind of forward kind of moving is it
creates this narrative of meaning I
could call the brand the hero,
my crew,
but you know,
it makes us this kind of hero.
It creates this very simplistic story
for,
for us to sort of sort of living live in
the middle of and the computer.
Can you describe.
It's quite.
It's quite fascinating actually because
as you describe it,
when you're the pirate,
the swashbuckling pirate,
your life is full of meaning and your
this heroic morally,
you know,
justified.
I know you're a part.
Yeah,
he is a pirate,
but what he's doing the little bit
ambiguous because there's quite a lot of
murder and bloodshed,
but sense that he's theory a bit,
but no,
he's on a journey of discovery because
there's some sub characters that go when
you're going to give up this piracy and
help us with our big.
So the subtext here.
Yeah,
okay.
yeah,
but it's this very,
again,
very,
very ancient Greek story of of meaning
and an individual kind of going out into
the world and causing great effects and
then suddenly switched back into this
office thing and you're just playing
this boring guy moving counters.
It's too close to the actual reality of
what you're doing.
Sat up at night playing on a
playstation.
You've covered generally just like
smacking your honor.
It's quite Meta.
It's quite metta.
They sang that the reality of the pirate
is not your ultimate reality and it may
be,
but that is again,
it's sort of a religious idea.
Like when you say this thing that you're
one's ego matrix makes you the hero of
your own life.
These scriptures that I'm forever
banging on about never bother bloody
reading,
tell you,
but there is no such thing as self.
You are not the hero of your own life.
You're just experiencing this data and
organizing.
It's a but really you all part of the
whole.
There is one.
This is the central tenet of all eastern
thinking.
Separation is an illusion.
You are experiencing this,
but the,
you are one.
You are one with all phenomenon.
Yeah.
Well I think,
I think there will be one thing I think
that goes back to these confucian ideas
of if you know of collectivity and it,
but I think the part of that,
the,
the modern kind of scientific kind of
does,
does bear out is,
is that,
is that we are,
that is this kind of illusion that we
are living in this kind of the story
which we live our lives in.
The middle of his is his,
uh,
is uh,
construction.
I mean,
what do we have?
What we really,
really know.
All we know is the information is
hitting our senses and our senses
experience that information is millions
and millions of little electrical pulses
and it uses those electrical policies
like computer code to build reality that
we experience is real.
All the colors and shapes and patterns
and sounds and it is a construction and
it is a story and and it makes us feel
important or meaningful like the pirate
in assassin's creed,
but really strip all that away and we.
What are we with the guy in the office
with the tiddlywinks in my tip link
alone will.
I've really enjoyed this.
What five books should pay.
Obviously we take for granted that
people should read your book Selfie.
What five books do think I should go and
rate isn't?
No,
I'm going to do good in it.
What the pertaining to these ideas now,
right?
See your clever right now.
Clever man will tell us five bucks to
read and you've got basically your five
favorite books.
You reckon we should rave when we'll get
out of it?
Okay,
cool.
well there you go.
Probably say sapiens off the top of my
head.
Where there were the,
I guess the,
the,
the two books that are kind of
essentially this is the geography of
thought rigidness bit which talks about
these Greek ideas.
Cool.
There's,
um,
the happiness hypothesis by an American
neuroscience psychology is called
Jonathan Haidt.
Height h a Idt.
That's cool.
That height,
because we don't have to be called hate,
like,
no,
I don't want to call them haters.
Let's call it kind of.
It's.
Got It.
Hi Jonathan.
Hi.
The book I'm reading reading at the
moment,
which I love the people of the rbs by
Jack London.
If you read the people at the rbs by
Now people.
Yeah.
So he say so it's an amazing book.
Wrote White Fang.
Yeah,
exactly.
So what he did,
he wrote a nonfiction book and I think
it was 19.
Oh,
two where he went in,
he saw the east end of London has this
amazingly dangerous wild place,
which it was.
And he dressed up as a poor person and
went into an adventure into who's
playing computer games in real life.
Yeah.
But it's amazing.
It's an amazing book and it's really
like some of those old books are very
difficult to read,
but it's really almost three of your
golf football,
potato.
He goes into a secondhand clothes shop
and get us all the garb and gets dressed
up and stuff and you know,
you talked about getting into that.
What's that famous is it cooks the map
shops still there in covent garden where
all the adventure is used to go and get
their maps of darkest Africa and he said
I'm going to journey into the east end
of London.
And they went,
well we can't help you with that.
That's dangerous.
So that's a really work of nonfiction,
which I didn't think sort of people kind
of know the bitch about the people of
the abyss and its description of what
these standards like in those days.
It's just extraordinary.
That edit and I'm sorta.
Could I have a yard a please fucking
fuck.
Who are deaf with my boner.
Sorry.
I tried to spend together too many
friends at the swearing.
So.
Well what's the next one?
We've done free done three.
Oh,
what else can I talk about?
I can talk about,
um,
a Star Zealand bat and a funder that's
one of my favorite nonfiction books.
Woo.
Sealand nothing book.
Yeah.
So she goes out into East Germany and
discoveries about the,
about the study,
but I guess the book,
my favorite book,
the maybe you want to be a nonfiction
writer is a book called bad wisdom by a
bill drummond x off the care and Mark
Manning of Zodiac mind open the love
reaction and,
and so,
but back in the wisdom yet it's an
amazing travel log that they decided to
try and save the world by driving to the
North Pole and a Ford escort and putting
an icon of Elvis Presley on it.
And it's there kind of in.
It's their story of them doing that.
And it's um,
the first,
the first line is I am shit scared,
shit,
scared of almost everything and never
opened that book going.
Got,
this book's going to be amazing.
And it is,
it's an amazing book.
I've even got his tattoo on my shoulder,
Zodiac mind,
there's a line that he says in the book
they're afraid.
So we are Zen masters and we know what
the fuck we're talking about.
One triangle thing is the zed is not a
very good tattoo in the middle.
So actual actual zed as superman.
When I was a boy,
right as superman,
I used to see the yellow bear,
not the red bit,
but I'd never knew until I was old.
That was a red s in the middle of his
chest.
Those to try and when I draw and draw
that logo,
I draw the yellow bits.
I have knowing that there was a red x in
the middle.
I had to sleep man wallpaper.
Exactly the same thing.
The yellow what?
Those yellow light shapes like whales
because it's an s in the middle.
Yeah.
That's a nice.
We were looking at the wrong color
wheel.
We wasted.
We're wasting our lives.
Garrett just did a Benny Hill blue
there,
which really brought me back to myself.
All right,
thanks man.
That's really cool.
Effects for those books.
Thanks for your time.
Beautiful.
Thank you.
That was under the skin with Russell
brand.
If you like that podcast,
give us five stars on itunes.
Is sponsored by me Russell Brand and my
rebirth to if you want to get Gary
Russell brand.com
or give us a kind of.
Oh,
that was so good.
Thank you.